розгорнувся в думена батальйон е-е
чеченський батальйон Шейха імені Шейха
Мансура І скільки ми знаємо Дружний вигляд
носами щось попросив організатор для
них один пікап але владно це ді
ви вирішили скинути і Петру Порошенку Та в
е-е поживно А що 160.000 ми
забрав і до того
менше
і я особливо швидко шляхах ось я знаю точно
хто е-е
Петро
метро
і
люди там сиськи
тому я абсолютно ще
історія
циприкватору я до спини і люди
відбулася і фонд Порошенка може
забезпечувати з бронею сили України
просто чому чеченський батальйон імені
Шейха Мансура Але їх чесно коротше
балують вагою
приїхала захищати Україну та
але Коли хвилі стояти на нашу можемо
приїхали Як почалося
Ну, як би в нас один спільний ворог приїхали
допомогти Україні знаходимося 14 роки тут
як друга війна почалася першого дня ми
тут вийшли
якраз машина Нам дуже навіть Потрібно
дві машини вони
уламками
Велике спасибі вам
машина стане в нагоді машина хороша
зараз ми
Запорізької області
у Харківській області дивимося там що
можна бути
батальйон займається розвідкою
диверсійними
диверсійними ось цими справами
засідки Загалом що можемо то Робін
допомагаємо засу разом із військовими теж на
завдання їдемо все, що наша сила ми
робимо ми за праву справу
тому що
ми не нападали На нас напали це наше
Це Земля Україна ми як би теж живемо
вже давно це вважаємо ми вважаємо Це
своєю другою Батьківщиною
і Україна переможе тому, що ми
боремося за праву Справу це Земля
України ми повернемося до нашої території
назад все до одного А щоб ви
росіянам сказали
ми будемо сказали Пушкіна вдома сидять у
себе і не лізуть до нас це не їх
території це не їхня справа ми обов'язково
переможемо і повернемо все своє назад